the truth is case is that I've been
locked up all these years for a crime I
didn't commit
okay and I'm ready to go home hopefully
I get that chance to go home that's the
truth
did you kill chip Flint no man did not
kill a young man how do you feel the
fact that there are some people who
think you did there would always be two
sides of a story give me my chance to
prove the tale my side will stir just
give me my chance to share my side story
whoever killed this man I wish they
would come forward is this the closest
you've felt up to now of a chance of
being able to either get a new trial or
go home yes in July of 2018 a federal
judge ruled that the prosecutor had
withheld material information from your
defense and and overturned your
conviction how did you find out oh you
know it was I was choked out it was due
a phone call and I was choked up I
really I couldn't it just like I
couldn't believe it
really I couldn't believe it and I was
lost words you know I really can't
describe me because I just like I'm
steadily now that's well I was just
holding the phone like this you know and
that was it you know I finally won I
finally won a point of getting a trial
what do you miss the most from your old
life we're the things I miss on country
being out in the country what's been the
hardest part about being in
as long the hardest part about being a
business loan is losing family members
close family members who've you lost
well the closest to all my two sisters
couldn't go to their funeral
okay good if you in tough death in tough
that's been tough 30 years 31 years
that's nothing
to break a man that's enough to destroy
a man but I want the people to know that
I'm not destroyed I'm not down I'm still
alive you know my hopes man is to get
now you know and it's gonna come soon
Lee it's gonna come when I can't tell
you but I can feel it you can feel it I
can feel it